[Music]
you have to pay attention
more um you're being played by the same
problem like you're painting the picture
that you think you're seeing okay I
think if
you slow down the video really you study
it you would see I'm not doing what you
think I'm doing
okay
um let's go back to some things so I I
only have two movements that's all I
have and those movements are very
important
because internally it's the loudong
that's turning and spiral rotating the
Tom Den which is
the undoing so to speak
of the yinong aspects okay you have to
spiral rotate to undo the
dichotomy
so with that in mind let me remind you
that things that are Yin will pass
through the yin phase into the Y phase
and vice versa do not expect something
to
stay uh in a permanent young phase or a
permanent Yin phase that's not
correct and most likely you're doing a
permanent y phase because that's the
fear phase okay and that is contesting
and more dichotomy and it's going to
make sense to you so so uh you're he's
he's driving you see and you're like
this you see that see that I'm not
letting them in okay and then you over
here and then you're like that and
you're not letting him in do you guys
understand that you guys see that okay
but this shape this shape what shape is
that that's no shape that's no shape
either that shape's not in the arm okay
and then you come
around and then you're on this
arm and you're doing this do you see and
again this shape's not in the
AR then you're over here so you're over
here and you're going like this a lot of
people go like this they want to Anchor
the elbow and they go like
this but that shapes not in the
art here
here two
circles this shape's not in the
AR then you go here that shape's not in
the ark you see this shape's not in the
art you right so
instead
Mo see the
difference okay I
move around watch this one remember in
and out is my relationship between my
wrist and elbow okay so as I'm coming
around inward SP
spiral into outward spiral right here he
comes
up outward spiral outward spiral inward
spiral in outward spiral inward
spiral inward spiral
some key things to look
for I don't have to
grab I don't have I will not be on top
of his arm camera over there I will not
be on top of his
arm I will not be inside his arm I will
not be on his shoulders
I'm on the
outside here this does everything that
they're trying to do
here no
no
together why together because
eventually this
arm is going to pass through
it's going to it's right here I have a
lot of energy then it starts to go down
so lot of Y goes through Yin and this is
where this picks up the
Y okay try it
again
e
e e
you're doing that uh last little
spiral you're going you're doing
this you see that he okay watch your
Center feel your Center feel your spine
okay do it again just relax you don't
need to do anything just feel it
watch so it's kind of going around your
spine you're kind of going like this pay
attention watch watch your body now
which way is it going it's going this
way pay
attention other one other one
there's no energy this way pay
attention you see you feel it I'll just
do that
energy you feel it on your left now okay
so two dimensional
Circle threedimensional
spiral watch where you fall now okay
watch where you're fall in relation to
me that not over here over here is
because there is another dimension of
force traveling up your spine
okay so it I don't even think it looks
to save myself
like this looks totally different to
me this one is this
way you
see but you can see that he's not
falling over there he's going around
around
me this way so now let's watch what that
does to this
hand if I throw him out
there my hands out
there so I have to like go
him whereas on this
one you
see you can bring him into
it's now virging your long face
again very similar to when we do
this you see got it okay so try it again
the internals like we because we're
learning them they are
um um very St
and and very linear right like we're
here okay and we're doing those kind of
things correct okay
um but
our architectures are not like that so
our keona for
example um
and you have to remember that those are
just beginner progressions and anytime
you have a beginner progression in some
way they're not right in some way are
wrong okay it's just by default so like
for
example
um we might practice and we have right
our draw stroke from concealment we and
we want to see how fast it go how fast
you get it out right but that's not the
way we actually fight with
concealment um to fight with concealment
is not to try to hurry up and beat that
guy but to take advantage of the fact
that they don't know your arm so instead
you look for distraction and for a lull
right and that might require that you do
it like this
as do you see that so some guy actually
did the stats on it he like looked at a
bunch of gunfights and overwhelmingly
the successful ones were not on The Fast
Draw but on a stealthy draw okay so the
beginner of working on mechanics and and
putting it on the clock and see how well
it can work right when you're facing and
the target it's not the way you actually
fight fight with it same thing with you
know the beginner law enforcement
officer you kind of stand still like
this and it's not no overwhel
statistically overwhelming we are moving
you see but that is a
more complicated cultivation field so we
keep you still in the beginning you see
and then you're supposed to progress
past that or another one that um I just
saw so the science on the quiet eye so
they plotted officer's eye movement and
this they put him in scenarios and the
skilled officers
overwhelmingly uh have the quiet eye
which is a uh the maintaining of the eye
on a particular thing um that assists
with aiming so basketball players do it
they stare at a point on the rim their
eyes not all over the place golfers do
do it tennis players Etc they brought
that into law enforcement now and they
saw overwhelmingly that the skilled
officers the ones that can navigate real
life calls or high stress scenario
training their eyes stay on the Target
and do not move okay
however when they train officers on how
to shoot they tell them focus on the
front s like we we've done that right
Focus Fus on the front sight focus on
the front sight and but the science is
that somewhere in there the skilled
officers learn what is called the stress
site picture and they're focused on the
target not the front sight you see so
somewhere in there you have to go from
the beginner front sight Focus to the
advanced stress site picture okay so in
that way from that perspective front
side focus is wrong that's just wrong
you can't fight with that okay all right
so the same thing we have our beginner
progressions and they gen they work
within a linear two-dimensional
environment it's going to be wrong okay
and one of the places that it's wrong is
if we look for example at when he's
driving at me so he has a linear thrust
that way okay that is a force that I can
ground do you see and depending on how
much I rebound it off the ground it will
either project right here do you see
that all right well when you have a
centrifugal
energy that is a
force that I can either project or
adhere however I want to okay so here
here he is and he has a linear Force but
once we start moving this is now I'm
going to take it this way you see and
his inertial wants to go out do you do
you understand that so as
I instead of like having to pull or
having to take this I am rebounding it
off of the ground at the uh equal Yar
that I need to adhere on the side of his
neck the same thing goes here the same
thing goes here if I'm over young or I'm
under then you always have to hook in
those two dimensional things but that
energy is trying to pull away from me
well it's trying to go that way do you
see and as I take it into the turn it's
still trying to go outward from the turn
but if I take it at a 90 to that and
when it's still it's very very hard to
adhere but once it wants to go out then
I can keep taking it out and I can get
the adhesion do do you get that okay so
that's you're doing that in all of this
technique
the whole technique the whole technique
is doing that it's using the centrifugal
energy to get the Y to
go to whether I project or whether I
adhere on it that means if I stop the UK
the centrifugal energy that you see me
using if you stop the UK it's not going
to be there and you have to do those
two-dimensional hooks all that kind of
stuff
here St the energy you got to go like
this you got to go like this right you
got to go like this you have to do
things to turn
him whereas if you keep him
moving get stuck on there as long as
you're
doing
that uh 90° fluctuation to it okay so
try to keep them moving and try to feel
exactly what you feel when we're working
in
two-dimensional environments
okay the point that Taylor got okay so
when you're coming
around okay this hand is going to go
into its Yin face
around
here a lot of people want to use this
shoulder power you you get the shoulder
and you go like that I used to do that
okay because you feel really powerful
because this never feels powerful
because you can tell your inner deltoid
is is [\h__\h] it up right so you put him
like right here and you're like you use
that but he I can't do I can't throw him
don't let me throw you
can't there's no freaking way okay
so this this hand this hand does it this
hand does it and does it in the motion
so the motion is going and then this
hand's doing it okay and then you follow
the
rules so let's start again the rules are
that the hands transfer
responsibilities as they reach that wui
wuji line here's where it goes you see
not not
before but
definitely not
after okay so you're always working in
here
boom boom here it
is piix it up there
okay try to remember that don't have it
before trying to use your chest here and
but definitely you shouldn't be throwing
them and then your arms hit in air or
it's not even needed okay all right try
to you're trying to use this centrifical
energy to generate your
adhesions uh as you're going
around he is not going to go from
here into the
throat that's not what he's going to
do so I can't stay
here and throw him this way
also this is a reactionary throw so as
he gets up it's not that I'm gonna go
like that because you you will give him
back his balance when he goes up that's
what you're taking this way you see
so uh I you I generally move around as
he goes up into
this so if you pay attention it's very
much like
K so as he gets up I am on one side of
his body and then I'm moving to the
other side of his body over here okay
but from the
back you're not moving it all Chris and
then
Andrew you are opening the
leg but it didn't do anything for you
you see you're just pulling back right
here instead you want to keep him going
forward
forward okay so yet he keeps moving so
that the centrifical energy generates so
that you can use
these arm patterns okay try it